people who obsessively play video games
could soon have a formal diagnosis of
addiction the World Health Organization
plans to classify gaming disorder as a
mental health condition in the newest
edition of its disease classification
manual Jamie yuccas shows how critics
are concerned that the move to help
gamers could be premature as a child you
know what I think what really attracted
me to games was that being born of
disability when I played games you know
people weren't able to judge me by how I
looked but rather by how I was in the
game for the last five weeks Kevin
Reilly has been undergoing an intensive
inpatient treatment program for his
video game habit I would definitely say
it was definitely an addiction for me we
get home from work at probably put in at
least six hours a night sometimes
upwards of 12 hours the World Health
Organization is considering formally
recognising gaming addiction as a mental
health condition the disorder which
experts say affects no more than 3% of
gamers has three main characteristics
loss of control over gaming habits
prioritizing gaming over other
activities and continuing to play
despite negative consequences we
definitely have seen an increase in
demand
Hillary cash co-founded restart one of
the nation's first treatment centers for
video game addiction phase one begins
with patients like Riley completely
unplugging so they're going essentially
through a detox they also are receiving
counseling and in general getting
physically fit
eating healthy catching up on sleep but
a division of the American Psychological
Association says it's concerned that the
current research base is not sufficient
to label gaming addiction as a disorder
which may be more a product of moral
panic than good science a physician
supported by the video game industry
still advocates are hoping the World
Health Organization's recognition will
prompt us insurance companies to cover
treatment which at restart can cost
upwards of $60,000 it's important
because now it will be taken seriously
as a legitimate disorder as for Riley
he's focused on taking back control of
his life there's no really no way to
avoid using technology altogether
in the future so I need to figure out a
way to balance that and integrate it
into my life in a healthy way
for CBS this morning Jamie yuccas Los
Angeles I tell you what this is starting
a conversation in every household who
has children who play games about the
amount of time they're spending in front
of that game and a conversation about
the psychological effects of Technology
which is long long overdue it is a
powerful powerful poll and especially
now that there are communities and you
have people with whom you interact so
the poll is not just things moving on a
screen but it's actual humans you're
connecting with Fortnite like your
friends are saying hey I'm on get on
with me let's let's play together